Also, herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu Folge 68 von das Podcast-UFO-Podcast mit Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will. Herzlich willkommen. Wir haben heute mal was Besonderes vor mit euch. Wir haben eine ganz besondere Idee gehabt, und zwar ist es die einzige Podcast-UFO-Folge, die ihr jemals hören werdet, die keinen einzigen Gag beinhaltet. Riecht ein. Wir werden, wer einen Gag macht, hat verloren, er hat diese Folge verloren.
Und die Folge ist beendet.
Und die Folge wird damit ab sofort beendet.
Also man kann sagen, wenn ich bei Minute zwölf einen Gag mache, ist die Folge vorbei, ist die zwölf Minuten lang. Was genau ist ein Gag? Das ist die Frage. Und war das schon einer? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das war nicht süffisant. Also ein Gag ist jedwige humoristische Auslegung der Realität, der zu einem Lachimpuls führend motiviert ist. Aber glaubst du denn, dass eine ernste Folge, wo wir keinen Gag machen, ein Gag per Definition, nicht auch einen Lachimpuls auslösen kann? Weil ich glaube, auch diese Folge ohne Gag, die wir bis zum Ende durchziehen, kann einen Lachimpuls erfolgen. Wir haben den Gag ja als die Elfform definiert, das heißt, man könnte jetzt sagen, das ist 77 Folgen lang, wurde diese Elfform etabliert, der lange Strich als Gag, Gag, Gag, Gag, Gag, Gag. Und heute ist mit der Folge 78 der Schlussstrich gezogen, die 90 Grad, kein Gag, was in sich wieder die Form eines Gags beinhaltet. Das ist so wie diese Flamingos, die sich von oben gesehen in der Form eines grossen Flamingos aufstellen.
Ja, weil du hast das gesehen bei so einem Footballspiel, diese Cheerleader, diese Marchband, die eine andere, diese Marchband, Marchband, Marching Band, Entschuldigung, kein Versprecher, hat sich eingeschlichen. Kein Witz. Und dann geht er quasi, wie Michael Jackson in seiner besten Zeit den Moonwalk gemacht hat, über das Feld. Eine fantastische, eine fantastische, spektakuläre Art, das mal zu sehen. Der Unterhaltung, ganz klasse. Solltet ihr, ihr seid die Schiedsrichter heute, solltet ihr irgendeinen Gag finden, auch irgendeine Art, auch sei es eine ungewollte Imitation, sei es ein lustiger Laut, ja, also aus dem Bereich der Phonetik, wenn uns da irgendwas über die Lippen quillt, auch dann. Was dann? Sollen sie dann anrufen oder was? Dann schreibt das als Heimkonten, dann erstens anrufen natürlich, also die Podcast-Uvo-Hotline. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. War kein Lachen. Ich war jetzt lustig, aber es war kein Gag. Nein, es war kein Gag. Also auf jeden Fall. Und schreibt dann den Timecode. Kurz mal, es war ein Gag. Also es war schon ein Gag. Also ich meine, aber egal. Ich meine, also jeder hat fünf drei Gags. Unter Vorbehalt, es war ein Gag. Jeder hat, also nein. Eins, null für mich. Okay. Schreibt es in die Kommentare, den Timecode, um alle Sünden festzustellen. Also, um mal möglichst jedem humoristischen Gefilde zu entschwinden. Stefan, wie geht's dir? Mir geht's sehr gut. Wobei ich mich gerade frage, war das, also wenn du vorher die Feedline aufbaust, dass jetzt im Folgenden kein Gag kommt und dann sagst, okay Stefan, was war denn los, ist das ein Gag, 2-0 für Stefan. Mir geht's sehr gut.
Ich finde das ein bisschen unfair, dass du jetzt bewertest, wer von uns beiden gewinnt und wer nicht. Aber gut.
Mir geht's ausserordentlich gut. Ich war eben zum ersten Mal wieder in der Uni, in der Universität.
Es war eine furchtbare Erfahrung mal wieder, weil ich gemerkt habe, dass ein Dozent am Start war, der nicht so viel drauf hat, fand ich. Und sobald ich das merke, nimmt man schnell so eine suffisante zynistische Haltung ein als ich. Und das war dann ja eigentlich relativ lustig, aber ich will jetzt nicht ins Detail gehen, sonst würde ich vielleicht einen Glack machen. Verstehe. Okay, also du bist dann durchaus gewillt, der Klassenclown zu sein. War ich früher gar nicht so. Bist du dann, also jetzt mal, du bist ja schon wahrscheinlich sowas wie ein Superstar. In der Uni auch in unserem Kurs, jetzt mal ganz uneitel gesprochen. Die werden ja wissen, dass du mal fürs Neo Magazin Real geschrieben hast, mittlerweile für einen mässig erfolgreichen YouTube-Kanal schreibst. Und dann wird man ja wahrscheinlich auch anders auf dich reagieren. Also ich möchte jetzt auch gerade aufs weibliche Geschlecht eingehen, dass man dann natürlich weiß, das ist ein Mann mit Kontakten, das ist ein Mann mit Erfahrung, der hat Berufserfahrung, die meisten wahrscheinlich nicht. Ähm, ja, ja. Und wenn du den Gag nur mir gegenüber machst, ich selte es mal nicht, weil es nicht nachprüfbar ist, aber an sich war das auch ein Juxus Minimalis, mein Freund. Ja, in dem Podcast machen wir keinen Gag, aber ich kann noch private nebenbei Faxen malen. Ja, der malt ja einen lustigen Comic nach dem anderen. Ja. Ach, war das auch korrigiert? Ja, ist nicht. Das ist doch albern. Nein, es war eine absurde Beschreibung der Realität. Ich meine, ich weiß es auch nicht. Naja, okay, nein. Also, lass mal, aber wie gehst du damit um? Nein, die wissen das. Ich bin jetzt auch, ich bin ja kein Star, auch wenn man, auch wenn die Neomagazin-Fans sind und wenn die wissen, dass, wenn die es cool finden, wenn die Bühne mal cool finden, wenn die die BTF cool finden, ist man ja trotzdem kein Star.
Man ist trotzdem noch ein Zugehörer. Man kennt dich, dir wird auf dem Gang schon hinterher geschaut und geraunt. Ja, es wird gemunkelt und da vorbehaltener Hand. Also ich weiss noch, als ich das allererste Mal beim Neo Magazin war, angekommen bin, das war glaube ich zu Folge drei oder fünf oder sowas, also wirklich recht früh, und da kam gerade davor erst dieser grosse Trailer raus, ich weiss nicht, ob du dich erinnerst, wo ganz lange diese One-Shot, wo ich zu sehen bin, wo du zu sehen bist, ja, und unter anderem ist auch Martin zu sehen, Martin Borchers, damals Produktionsleiter, mittlerweile immer noch, und als ich den alleine schon gesehen habe, auf dem Hof vom Neo Magazin Büro, war ich schon komplett starstruck, einfach weil ich wusste, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat was mit dem, der hat, der hat was mit dem, der hat, der hat was mit dem, der hat, der hat das mit dem, der hat, der hat das mit dem, der hat, der hat, der hat das mit dem, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der hat, der ich schon komplett starstruck. Einfach weil ich wusste, der hat was mit dem Projekt zu tun, der hat was mit Jan Böhrmann zu tun, auch wenn der selber in der Sendung gar nicht vorkommt, war das für mich schon ein starstruck Moment. Und du auch, also dich habe ich jetzt nicht mehr so in Erinnerung gehabt, dass du in dem Trailer warst, aber auch du so von wegen, oh der gehört da dazu und der geht mit einer Lässigkeit durch diese Räume, die man selber gar nicht hat, weil man extrem aufgeregt ist und irgendwie hinter jeder Ecke Superstar war. Aber das ist ja, glaube ich, du hast den Leuten, die haben dir was voraus, weil die in dem Moment nicht mehr, weil das für die eine normale Situation ist und für dich schon. Und das glaube ich, deswegen wird man noch nervöser und die noch entspannter, weil die einfach von sich aus die bessere Default-Position haben, gerade in diesem Moment, die sind eher in ihrer Comfortzone und deswegen ist es glaube ich immer noch mehr Starstruck. Ich glaube, worauf man ja eigentlich neidisch ist, dass die Situation, die für einen selbst besonders ist, für den anderen gar nicht mehr besonders ist. Genau. Also die gehen mit einer völligen Selbstverständlichkeit, gehen die an Jan Böhrmann vorbei, mit einer absoluten Selbstverständlichkeit, sehen die in der Regie irgendwie lesende Skript, schauen ins Publikum, sind gar nicht aufgeregt. Darauf ist man ja neidisch. Man möchte ja eigentlich das Besondere zur Normalität werden lassen. Früher beim Theater fand ich es auch immer total abgefahren, da gab es ein Theaterstück, wo das Publikum und die Bühne vertauscht wurde, wo das Stück im Publikumsraum gespielt hat und das Publikum auf der Bühne saß. Was eine gute Idee ist. Mega geil. Und da mussten wir dann halt auch alle Backstage gehen. Das ganze Publikum wurde dann im Foyer gesammelt und dann als die Forschung losging, kam dann so ein Mitarbeiter und der hat den dann durchs ganze Backstage geführt, weil man ja auf die Bühne musste. Und da ist man dann auch an den ganzen Umkleideräumen der Schauspiele vorbeigesehen. Und du warst im Publikum und hast zum ersten Mal Backstage gesehen und fand es wahnsinnig. Richtig, war dann auch auf der Bühne. Mega gut und da ist mir zum Beispiel auch Rainer Bock entgegengekommen, damals noch im Residenztheater gespielt. Der hat auch mitgespielt bei dem großen Flugzeugabschiessen, ja oder nein, Thriller. Da können wir gleich nochmal drauf eingehen. Aber der hat da auch mitgespielt und der auch in Glorious Barsons eine kleine Rolle hatte. Der ist mir da entgegengekommen und der ist auch mit einer völlig Selbstverständlichkeit da rausgekommen, hatte so ein Handtuch, er hatte nur so ein Unterhemd an, Handtuch über der Schulter, wunderbar riesige Erektionen, stand, ach scheiße, fuck story, scheiße. Aber das war ein sehr offensichtlicher Gag, nicht mehr vertuscht. Auf jeden Fall, 3-0, auf jeden Fall kam er da entgegen und das Besondere, was ich an dem so beeindruckend fand, war, dass er mit einer völligen Natürlichkeit und völliger Selbstverständlichkeit in diesem Theater, in dieser Backstage-Atmosphäre gehaust hat.
Und das fand ich so interessant, dass es ein
Arbeitsplatz ist, das, was andere
als besonderes, also wenn du jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Legoland arbeitest, da wo andere den
tollsten Tag ihres Lebens haben, ist es für andere
der Arbeitsplatz. Und das ist ja eigentlich das Interessante.
Und das hast du auf jeden Fall anderen Leuten voraus,
auch wenn du jetzt kein großes Licht beim Neo-Magazin warst
und jemals warst.
Oder jemals sein wirst. Nö. Ich glaube jedenfalls, ich bin auch nervös, wenn ich so einen Menschen, der, wie gesagt, die Achterbahn von Phantasialand, ähm, ja, der die, ich bin, also ich bin starstruck, wenn ich dem, wenn ich dann vorne an der, an dieser Schwingtür stehe und der die Macht gerade bei mir hat, mich da reinzulassen und nicht, und mein Bügel testet, dem vertraue ich in dem Moment auch mein Leben an und irgendwie ist es schon ein geiler Job und ich denke mir, der arbeitet jeden Tag in der Achterbahn, das finde ich schon geil und dann bin ich in dem Moment auch so ein bisschen nervös, mit dem könnte ich nicht normal reden, glaube ich, da bin ich ein bisschen nervös. Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht gar keine so schlechte Karriereentscheidungswahl. Sucht euch da einen Job, wo andere Leute hingehen, um Spaß zu haben. Oder wo andere Leute nach... Im Kino, im Schwimmbad, das sind, glaube ich, immer coole Jobs. Geht nicht in so ein Amt oder so, wo Leute ungern hingehen, weil da ist die Arbeit vielleicht auch schlecht. Geht lieber dahin, wo die Leute... Gut, da stellst du halt, dass alle Leute so wie wir Anerkennung und Liebe suchen, weil das ist ja der Grund, warum man... Auch eine Form von Macht. Aber das ist natürlich auch, was Menschen wollen, das kann man nicht unterstellen. Zum Fernsehexperiment, was in aller Munde ist, auch in beiden Vorlesungen, wo ich heute war, zum Thema gemacht wurde, das ist das alte Experiment, das alte Weichen. Ja, das ist so lächerlich. Das ist ein Weichendilemma, wo ich mir denke, das ist das älteste, in jedem Assessment-Center spielt man, würdest du das Futterflugzeug abschießen oder nicht?
Das spielt man überall, das ist das älteste Rätsel, Dilemma, moralisch Dilemma der Menschheit. Es ist aber moralisch gesehen nicht genau dasselbe, weil bei dem Weichendilemma entscheidet man sich, soll einer sterben oder fünf, wohingegen, wenn du das Flugzeug nicht abschießt, ja sowohl alle in dem Haus als auch alle in dem Flugzeug sterben.
Das heißt, die in dem Flugzeug sterben so oder so. Und zusätzlich geht es nur darum, ob noch die in dem Haus sterben.
Also bei der Weiche entscheidest du dich, ob eins oder fünf, bei dem anderen dann dementsprechend fünf oder sechs.
Ja.
Ne, eins oder sechs. Also stehen nur die in dem kleinen Flugzeug oder alle in dem ganzen Ding. Aber auf der einen Seite ist die Frage ... Es ist die alte Frage Moralphilosophie oder Usilitarismus eigentlich. Weil Moralphilosophisch ... Ja, aber die haben wir auch schon vor 500 Jahren beantwortet mit Nein, fuck it, wie würde es Menschen jetzt unantastbar, du kannst nicht Leute umbringen als Staat, dann. Genau, man hat sich irgendwann entschieden, halt moralphilosophisch mitzugehen und nicht zu sagen, zwei Menschenleben sind mehr wert als ein Menschenleben, sondern jedes Menschenleben ist gleich wert. Du kannst als Staat nicht die Entscheidung treffen, unschuldige Bürger zu töten. So, und das war in meinem Kopf auch irgendwie klar. Und jetzt frage ich mich, warum redet jeder darüber, als er es das krasseste Rätsel, was die Menschheit jemals gesehen hat. Ich verstehe das einfach nicht und ich glaube, es liegt daran, weil man, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen arrogant, weil man schon mal... Weil die Dummsinn. Ja. Und weil die Leute eher auf der Seite von Richard David Fitz oder Florian Fitz, Ulrich, was auch immer. Ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht 80 Gags waren in einem Satz. Das waren auch, oh mein. Ja, ja. Nee, es ist, glaube ich, das ist halt einfach die Frage, zwischen Konkreten und Abstrakten zu unterscheiden. Ich finde es so gut, dass wir ernst reden in dieser einen Folge, wo wir so Stative haben wie so Radiomoderatoren. Und ich höre jetzt, gestern bin ich im Car2Go gefahren und da lief war WDR4 oder WDR3 eingestellt, die ganze Zeit so ein Labersender, wo die so ganz nah am Mikrofon waren und dann über die, über Krebskrankheiten gesprochen haben.
Und das ist schon ein bisschen interessant, also das macht schon viel mit einem.
Und das finde ich ganz cool, dass wir diese Folge ausgesucht haben.
Ah, okay, Alter.
Ich habe mich gerade mega an einem Stativ, sorry, eingezwickt.
Okay.
Es ist aufnahmetechnisch, obwohl es die Folge ist, wo wir keine Gags machen, die lustigste bislang, weil es passiert so viel lustiges Zeug. Aber wie gesagt, du hast schon recht, also man ist dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen arrogant, aber ich glaube auch, es ist schon, wenn sich die Leute ein bisschen mehr mit Philosophie beschäftigt hätten, dann wäre das jetzt heutzutage auch kein großes Thema mehr. Vor allem, es ist ja interessant, dass viele Leute ja nicht die Abstraktionen können zwischen eigener Meinung und dem, was allgemeiner Meinung sollte. Also zum Beispiel in dem Film Ives of March wird George Clooney gefragt, sind Sie gegen die Todesstrafe, ja oder nein, ja, ich bin gegen die Todesstrafe und dann würden Sie nicht denn einen Mensch, der ihre Frau vergewaltigt hat, würden Sie den nicht gerne umbringen? Dann sagt er, doch, natürlich, ich würde den Menschen umbringen, der meine Frau vergewaltigt hat, aber als System, das System darf nicht so denken wie ein Individuum, wie ein Einzelnes. Als System musst du natürlich die Todesstrafe ablesen, auch wenn du als Einzelner die Todesstrafe in dem konkreten Modus befürworten würdest. Und diese einfache Trennung, glaube ich, sind viele Menschen einfach nicht in der Lage zu sehen, dass einfach was ich als richtig erhalte, ist nicht deswegen automatisch schon dafür qualifiziert, als allgemeine Regel zu ergeben. Weil das auch eine gewisse Reflexionsgabe voraussetzt, die viele, glaube ich, einfach nicht haben, beziehungsweise die erst kommt, wenn man sich ein bisschen mehr damit beschäftigt. Interessanterweise wurde das ja auch in vielen Ländern gezeigt, der bestimmte Film oder das Buch wurde auch in vielen Ländern gelesen, das gab auch ein Theaterstück und da haben quasi die meisten Leute immer gesagt, der ist nicht schuldig. Genau, obwohl bei dem Theaterstück noch mehr Leute gesagt haben, er ist schuldig, als jetzt bei dem dummen Fernsehen. Tatsächlich, beim Theaterstück weiß ich nicht genau, aber der Film wurde in ein paar anderen Ländern gezeigt, und da war oft das Kino, es ging um Vorstellungen, ich glaube, das ging auch um das Theaterstück. Und da war wirklich in den meisten Ländern, wurde das fünfmal gezeigt, das Stück, und fünfmal haben die Leute gesagt, die sind nicht schuldig, der Typ. Und wohingegen in Japan wurde es viermal gezeigt und viermal haben Leute gesagt, der ist schuldig. Und es ist in keinem anderen Land, es ist komplett um 180 Grad gedreht worden. In jedem anderen Land ist meistens fünf von fünf, vier von vier, sieben, dreißig von achtunddreißig dafür, dass er unschuldig ist. In Japan ist es komplett andersrum, also komplett. Die sind nicht einig, sondern die sind komplett anderer Meinung. Ich finde das so spannend. Das ist interessant. Weil woran liegt das? Also erstmal natürlich anderes Menschenbild. Ich hätte aber gesagt zum Beispiel, was auch ein bisschen naiv ist, aber ich hätte gesagt, in Japan ist ein Menschenleben weniger wert. Hätte ich jetzt spontan, wäre mein erster Impuls gewesen, zu sagen. Ist zumindest so das Klischee, dass man sagt, die Kultur der einzelnen ist weniger wichtig, wichtig ist die Firma als Ganzes oder das Land oder die Familie oder eher der Gruppe Verband ist wichtiger als das einzelne Individuum, wohingegen man in westlichen Kulturen eher sagt, das Individuum ist wichtiger als der Verband. Aber würde man einem Volk, wo das Individuum weniger wert ist, nicht eher sagen, da geht es dann darum, also würde man dem nicht eine andere Entscheidung unterstellen? Würde man dem nicht die Entscheidung unterstellen, dass der Mann nicht schuldig ist, weil er die meisten Menschen gerettet hat, weil das Gro, also das einzelne Leben ist nicht viel wert, sondern es geht um die Gemeinschaft, wo die Gemeinschaft überlebt. Also wenn ich einem Land stellen würde, dass es utilitaristisch in Anführungszeichen entscheidet, dann Japan. Aber es geht ja nicht um Individuum gegen Gruppe, sondern es geht ja um konkretes Dilemma gegen abstraktes Prinzip. Und das kann man, glaube ich, nicht so einfach übertragen. Kannst du das ausführen nochmal? Habe ich gerade schon ausgeführt.
Nochmal einfach.
Ich würde es gerne nochmal hören. Nee, aber wir machen ja gerade auch denselben Fehler, dass wir auch jetzt selber nochmal drüber reden, weil gerade alle drüber reden. Wir sind gegen den Hype, wir reden etwas, wir reden
über die
österreichische Volksversammlung von 1968,
über die redet nämlich niemand, und wir schauen uns heute nochmal an, wie die
Parteienabstimmung da abgelaufen ist. Dafür haben wir einen kleinen Einspieler vorbereitet, den hört ihr jetzt mit was. Boah, Alter, ob das funktioniert mit dem, ich weiß nicht, ob das funktioniert mit dem, keine Gags machen oder so. Ich glaube nicht, wir machen unterschiedlich immer Gags. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob wir wirklich in der Lage sind, spontan ein ernsthaftes Gespräch auch stattfinden zu lassen. Ich finde, das funktioniert. Ja, da war jetzt nicht irgendwie viel Intimität dabei oder so. Das ist halt einfach, wir haben unsere Meinung gesagt, die jetzt auch unan... Das ist genauso, wenn man sagt, man ist gegen Rassismus. Das ist nicht intim oder tief oder ernst, das ist einfach nur... Aber haben wir oft, wenn wir privat reden, keine Mikros an sind, haben wir auch schon mal ernste Gespräche geführt? Ja, aber das ist dann halt oft über sehr konkrete Sachen. Also ich glaube, über so allgemeine Dinge eher wenig. Liegt auch daran, glaube ich, ich habe eher Meinungen, was mich konkret betrifft und selten. Also ich glaube, ich bin zu zynisch, was keine gute Eigenschaft ist, soll nicht kokettiert sein, aber ich habe oft, was die Allgemeinheit angeht, ein zu schlechtes Menschenbild, um irgendwas an Meinung mitzubringen, glaube ich. Das ist auch keine gute Eigenschaft, das habe ich auch noch nie so gesagt. Das ist auch ein bisschen schön, wenn man ein bisschen erst will. Ich glaube, man muss auch nicht immer eine Meinung haben, weil eine Meinung ja in den meisten Fällen in irgendeiner Weise extrem ist. Also du bist entweder dagegen oder dafür, aber es gibt nicht so diese Mittelmeinung, so dieses, ja, die so ein bisschen und diese. Und wenn du sagst, aber hast deine Meinung zur Todesstrafe, musst du entweder dafür oder dagegen sein, aber man kann nicht sagen, so, ach, ich weiß, ich habe mir jetzt noch nicht so viel Gedanken gemacht, weiß ich nicht irgendwie, vielleicht, ich glaube, es ist manchmal auch ganz gut, einfach keine Meinung zu haben, einfach zu sagen, so, fag geht. Erwartet man von unserer Generation überhaupt eine Meinung, oder erwartet man, anders gesagt, erwartet man von dir eine Meinung als Unterhalter, also Unterhaltung ist ja auch theoretisch Haltung. Ich glaube letztlich nicht wirklich. Also das werde ich oft gefragt, auch so aus den Kommentaren oder so. Leute schreiben mir, was ist deine Meinung zu dem und dem Thema oder was findest du besser, Star Wars oder Hell der Ringe? Ich glaube, man will da auch einfach nur das hören, was man selber denkt. Also was ist dein Lieblingsfilm oder was auch immer? Da glaube ich, wollen die Leute eher sich selber bestätigt sehen oder was ist, solche Sachen, was ist deine Meinung zu abschliessen, ja oder nein, fragen Leute eher, um sich selber bestätigt zu sehen, weil der, zu dem sie in gewisser Weise aufschauen, irgendwie die gleiche Meinung haben sollen, als dass man jetzt wirklich wissen möchte, warum und wie der Mensch denkt und fühlt, sondern dass man sich eigentlich bestätigt hören möchte. Aber oft ist ja auch das ganze Teil des eigentlichen Prozesses, zum Beispiel mit dieser Killerspieldebatte, die ist jetzt noch ein bisschen abgeklungen, deswegen kann ich Kametzer noch wieder drüber reden, aber gerade bei dieser Killerspieldebatte, als sie damals noch mit diesem Amoklauf gedöhnt, und dann hieß es hier, hat irgendein CSU-Politiker gesagt, von wegen Amoklaufdebatte und so. Und da war ja die Debatte das eigentliche Ablenkungsmanöver.
Da wurde die Debatte ja angefacht dafür, damit man eigentlich nicht über das wirkliche Thema sprechen muss.
Also du hast das Problem, du hast Gewalt, Waffengewalt ist das Problem.
Und dann schmeißt ein Politiker die Rauchgranate, Killerspiele, ja oder nein?
Und alle reden Killerspiele, ja oder nein?
Und jeder holt seine Meinungstafel raus und sagt hier, obwohl diese ganze Debatte die eigentliche Ablenkung war und der Politiker ist der absolute Gewinner der gesamten Diskussion, weil der sich mit dem eigentlichen Problem nicht befassen muss, weil er seinen Auftrag schon erfüllt hat. Okay, jetzt unterstellst du ja den Politikern in dem Moment, und das ist blöd zu sagen, den Politikern, weil ich... Nee, nicht dem konkreten.
Okay, aber du unterstellst ihm aber eine gewisse Gerissenheit, oder warum, also warum, was ist dein Motiv, was ist dein Motiv, von der eigentlichen Thematik abzudenken, weil die ist lösbar, da kann man eine Meinung zu haben. Ja, aber das ist schwierig zu lösen, das ist nicht einfach zu lösen, zu sagen, Waffenkontrolle und wie viele Ausländer haben, wie viele Waffen und Gesetze und Zoll und Gedöns und Ausländer und wie viele bla. Das ist ein schwieriges Thema. In den USA ist es einfacher zu lösen. Nee, aber es ist einfacher zu sagen, man eröffnet die Killerspieldebatte und da gerade die Leute, gerade liberale Leute oder so, die eigentlich da irgendwie vielleicht konkrete politische Oppositionen gegen diesen CSU-Politiker gegeben hätten, steigen auch total auf die Killerspieldebatte ein und machen sich dann da kaputt. Und vor allem das Interessante ist ja, dass eher darüber debattiert wurde, wie die Debatte geführt wird, aber die Debatte selber gar nicht geführt wurde, sondern sich alle aufgeregt haben, jetzt kommt wieder die Killerspieldebatte und oh mein Gott, aber das war eigentlich die eigentliche Debatte über die Debatte, nicht die Debatte selbst. Und damit wurde eine komplette Rauchgranate gezündet und alle waren abgelenkt. Aber das weiß ich nicht, ob das beim Gro der Bevölkerung Deutschlands auch so angekommen ist, weil wir leben halt auch in Blasen, wir leben in Medienblasen und wir kriegen oft Debatten über Debatten mit, weil wir nun mal in einer Medienblase leben. Ich würde immer unterstellen, dass es den meisten Leuten in Deutschland nicht so ging, sondern die eher die Debatte geführt haben. Ja, das weiß ich.. Gut, das stimmt. Er sieht blasen, kann man natürlich immer sagen. Aber was gerade in der Zeit auch so bei Moin Moins oder so an mich herangetragen wurde im Chat so, was sagst du zur aktuellen Killerspiel-Debatte? Also gar nicht, was ist deine Meinung zu Killerspielen? Ich meine, die ist relativ klar, offensichtlich, aber sofort die Frage, was hältst du zur Debatte? Und die wollen dann hören, es ist total scheiße, dass alle wieder über die Killerspiel-Debatte, bla bla bla, was aber eine komplette Ablehnung ist. Eigentlich, wenn der Politiker gesagt hat, oh Killerspiel, hätte man sagen müssen, darüber müssen wir gar nicht reden, weil das ist ein albernes Argument. Lass uns da doch gar nicht drüber reden, wir werden diese Debatte nicht führen, weil da müssen wir nicht drüber reden, sondern wir müssen über die eigentlichen Probleme reden. Also eigentlich eher sagen, der Versuch, die Debatte zu entfachen, soll scheitern und wir haben gerade keine Meinung zu irgendwas, sondern ist einfach ein Thema. Das ist wie wenn jemand sagen würde, lass uns doch mal drüber diskutieren, ob man Frauen vergewaltigen soll oder nicht und alle diskutieren und naja, hier, klar, obwohl man eigentlich sagen sollte so, nein, wir werden die Debatte natürlich nicht führen, das ist doch klar. Genau. So, dann, die Debatte selber ist das eigentliche Problem, weil sie zu nichts führt und eigentlich von allem ablenkt. Und das kann man jetzt sagen, weil die Debatte nicht mehr geführt wird, aber auch damals habe ich bewusst nichts dazu gesagt, weil ich das eigentlich das Problem fand, dass sich jeder positioniert und jeder eine Meinung hat und jeder sofort einen Blogtext schreibt und sagt, wie dumm die anderen alle sind. Aber glaube ich, der eigentlich richtige Reaktion gewesen wäre, einfach komplett das zu ignorieren und nicht darauf aufzustellen, sondern einfach zu sagen, wir führen diese Debatte gar nicht, die verdient nicht unsere Aufmerksamkeit. Aber ist es nicht menschlich zu sagen, also dieses Debatte über Debatte führen, das sind diese Fraktale, dieses rein menschliche Bedürfnis, einzuordnen, was passiert, das einzuordnen, halt weiterzugehen, weiterzugehen und auch, dass wir jetzt über den Film sprechen und nicht über das eigentliche Problem, das gestern gezeigt wurde. Aber das ist ja kein Problem, das ist ja genau das Ding. Das ist ja gesetzlich geregelt, da gibt es ja überhaupt nichts zu diskutieren, auch schon seit Kant. Das ist ja alles schon vergessen. Es ist trotzdem ein moralisches Dilemma, was er... Nee, klar. Es ist natürlich ein Dilemma, aber es ist kein gesellschaftliches, rechtliches Dilemma, weil das alles schon vor Jahrhunderten geklärt wurde. Gut, aber es wurde auch nicht vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber trotzdem wurde, es wird
über den Film gesprochen, es wird auch
nicht die Grundsatzfrage gestellt.
Das ist oft ein Problem, dass man zum Kern der
Frage gar nicht mehr durchdringt, weil man davor
tausend andere Themen erstmal abklappern muss,
bevor man zur Grundfrage kommt. Aber das ist ja auch
normal. Ich glaube, das Problem ist auch oft,
dass man sich über Debatten
in neuen Debatten echauffiert, was
nichts bringt. Wenn du sagst, oh, momentan reden alle über Dschungelcamp, dann gibt es immer Dschungelcamp, dann gibt es die Leute, die sagen, oh, wie nervig, dass gerade alle über Dschungelcamp reden, dann die, die sagen, oh, wie nervig, dass es gerade alle nervig finden, wir lassen es einfach reden. Die eigentlich richtige Reaktion wäre einfach nichts zu sagen. Einfach zu sagen, das Thema nicht grösser zu machen, weil oft macht ja der Anti-Hype das Thema noch viel grösser als der eigentliche Hype. Die Leute, die es sich anschauen, schauen es an, aber eigentlich erst durch dieses, das ist so nervig und dann kommt das Filter dagegen, dass man das rausfiltern kann und dann die Diskussion. Das Phänomen des ironischen Guckens, des ironischen Handelns, das ein Paradoxon ist, weil das Ausüben der Handlung widmet dem Thema so viel, dass Ironie nicht vorhanden ist. Ich kann nicht ironisch Schwiegertochtergesuch gucken, ich kann nicht ironisch mitten im Leben gucken, du guckst es nicht ironisch, weil du es schaust. Und genau so ist es ja oft auch gedacht, also ist es ja glaube ich auch oft so gedacht, dass man es genauso schaut. Dschungelcamp ist das beste Beispiel, die machen ja da gar keinen grossen Hehl drum, dass man es genauso ironisch schaut. Und da kommentiert sich das Programm ja selber schon ironisch.
War das denn immer so? Das weiß ich gar nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das immer so war. Ich habe das früher nicht geschaut, aber früher, glaube ich, war das dann nicht so, dass man sagt, wir machen hier Trash-Fernsehen und RTL pumpt so und so viel Geld in den Dschungel, wie es heute offensichtlich ironisch gemacht wurde.
Um das dem Zuschauer sogar abzunehmen, ist ironisch zu schauen, sondern der kann es mittlerweile wieder normal schauen, aber die Ironie nimmt das Programm ihm schon ab. Er ist auch dieser Aufgabe schon befreit. Das muss er gar nicht mehr machen. Ist so ein bisschen das Big-Short-Phänomen, der Film über die Finanzkrise, wo irgendwann erklärt wird, wie das ganze Kartenhaus in sich zusammengefallen ist, nämlich dass bei einer Wette eine Nebenwette auf die Wette abgeschlossen wurde, wieder eine Wette darauf abgeschlossen wurde, also eine nie endende Kette, weil es immer einfacher ist, das Vorliegende zu bewerten, als das Dahinterliegende. Das heißt, um das nicht durchzugraben, schließt man eine Wette ab auf das, was man vor sich hat. Dass der aber das genauso macht und der davor genauso und das eine Riesenkette mit sich bringt, ist natürlich dann auch wieder eine neue Sache. Ich glaube, auch dem Mensch fällt es generell sehr leicht, sich über andere Menschen aufzuregen. Eher als über andere Probleme oder abstrakte Sachen. Dass man sagt, okay, Dschungelcamp, wir haben hier diese Problematik, wie weit dürfen Medien gehen, inwiefern sind die selber verantwortlich, alle diese relativ schwierigen Probleme und es ist einfacher, sich über den dummen RTL-Zuschauer aufzuregen, der so dumm ist, es ist einfacher, auf den Menschen zu zeigen und zu sagen, du bist asozial, du bist scheiße, anstatt sich diesem eigentlichen Themen zu widmen. Deswegen glaube ich, werden diese Mechanismen immer mächtiger, je weiter sie nach außen gehen, weil es immer mehr menschlicher wird und man immer sagen kann,
oh, die Leute, die jetzt schon wieder Wham hören
zur Weihnachtszeit, oh, die ganzen Leute,
die jetzt schon wieder die Weihnachtsdekoration
raushängen, es wird immer menschlicher,
je weiter man nach außen geht und es wird immer einfacher
draufzudreschen, weil das Einfachste, worauf
man schlagen kann, ist ein Mensch,
der irgendwas nach außen zeigt, der sagt,
oh, ich bin Fan von dem deutschen
Nationalmannschaft und dann darauf zu schlagen,
so Nationalismus oder irgendwas oder bla bla
oder assi, das ist dann extrem leicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass man, also manchmal
hatte ich, ich hatte so eine Phase in meiner Jugend,
wo man, wo ich eine Meinung hatte,
weil von mir verlangt wurde, eine Meinung zu haben.
Es wurde mir gefragt, wie
fandest du Batman Begins?
Und ich habe gesagt, gut oder
schlecht, weil, aber das sind doch Gründe, die man sich gerade ausdenkt. Also ich habe nie da gesessen und gesagt und eine Pro- und Kontra-Debatte geführt, warum ich Batman Begins gerade gut oder schlecht finde, sondern es ist ein Gefühl. Also man hat ein Gefühl, wenn man einen Film guckt oder so. Aber mittlerweile habe ich das Gefühl, also will man einen Film in eine Schublade pressen, gut oder schlecht? Weil von einem verlangt wird, eine Meinung zu haben. Leute fragen mich, wenn ich aus dem Kino gegangen bin, wie fandest du den Film? Und deswegen sitzt man da, während man den Film guckt und überlegt sich, wie finde ich das eigentlich gerade, statt den Film zu gucken und das zu finden, was man fühlt. Das ist komplett egal mittlerweile. Es kommt nur noch darum, es in Schubladen zu stecken. Und es ist ja auch schwer, welches Vokabular man überhaupt benutzt, wenn man darüber spricht, ob ein Film gut war oder nicht. Wenn man sagt, ich fand ihn gut, warum? Welche Art von Begriffen verwendet man da jetzt? Soll man jetzt irgendwie das aus Produktionssicht bewerten, irgendwie Kamera war gut oder soll man sagen, es ist ja schwer, wie redet man da überhaupt drüber, weil ja allein schon dieses subjektive Urteil einfach per se subjektiv ist und eigentlich nicht erklärbar ist und die Idee eines Films ja auch ist, dass der Film als solches in den Hintergrund tritt und man bestenfalls am Ende gar nicht so weiß, dass man gerade einen Film durchlebt hat, der irgendwie mit Regisseur und Kamera und die Schauspieler, sondern dass man irgendwie in einer anderen Welt war und was erlebt hat und dann rauskam und bestenfalls gar nicht drüber nachdenkt, den Film, also das Medium zu bewerten, anstatt einfach, boah, das ist schon krass, Superheld, seine Frau zu verlieren oder seine Eltern zu verlieren. Sollen bestenfalls glücklicher zu sein als vorher. Ja, oder bestenfalls irgendwie Erlebnisse gehabt haben, ohne auf die vermittelnde Instanz überhaupt zu achten, sondern einfach zu sagen, boah, das ist schon krass. Ich frag mich dann oft auch ... Also, ich steh bei Filmkritiken oft so skeptisch der Filmkritik gegenüber,
dass ich manchmal sage, gut, das hättest du jetzt eins zu eins auch komplett in die andere Richtung argumentieren können. Ich bin der Meinung, am Anfang steht die These, wie man den Film fand, und dann argumentiert man darauf hinaus. Das ist bei allem so. Auch wenn ich meine Bachelorarbeit jetzt anfange zu schreiben, ist da voll die These. Und dann fängst du an, das zu begründen. Aber egal, also ich könnte die Bachelorarbeit auch komplett drehen. Auch einen Monitorbeitrag, wir haben einen Dozent von Monitor, das Investigativmagazin. Und das ist ein Meinungsmagazin, die machen knallharte Beiträge, die berichten knallhart aus dem Geschehen. Ungeschminkt meinst du? Ungeschminkt. Und ich frage mich dann auch manchmal, ob da nicht auch zuerst die Meinung stand und dann wurde daraufhin das recherchiert. Wenn die eine andere Meinung gehabt hätten, hätten die auch in die andere, hätten die andere Leute gefragt. Natürlich. Und ich glaube, manchmal ist einfach die Meinung zuerst da und dann wird darauf hingehend argumentiert. Was menschlich ist, aber was man sich bewusst machen soll. Deswegen, Filmkritiken sind eigentlich komplett egal. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und vor allem, es ist ja auch, also nicht jeder Film will ja gefallen in der Hinsicht, will ja nur positive Gefühle ausdrücken. Zum Beispiel, ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass ich mit meinem Deutschen Karma in einem Theaterstück war, in so einem ganz kleinen muffligen Theater, das auch mega experimental war, wo auch alle nackt waren und sich gegenseitig bespuckt und mit Scheisse überschmissen haben und so, mega abgefahren und so. Und danach haben wir darüber gesprochen und mein Lehrer, der LK-Leiter meinte, ja, er fand das Stück sehr schlecht und er konnte die ganze Nacht nicht schlafen, weil es ihn so beschäftigt hat. Und da habe ich mir schon gedacht, ist das nicht ein Widerspruch an sich? Weil anscheinend hat dich das Stück so berührt und auf so eine Art getroffen,
dass du die ganze Nacht nicht schlafen konntest und drüber
nachgedacht hast und es irgendwie versucht hast zu verarbeiten.
Eigentlich kann es doch dann gar nicht mehr
schlecht sein. Das ist ja empirisch bewiesen,
dass es einen Effekt, irgendwie auf dich
zu wirken und irgendwas in dir auszulösen,
relativ offensichtlich erfüllt
hat. Und damit kann es eigentlich nicht schlecht sein,
auch wenn es jetzt vielleicht negative Emotionen
oder irgendwie was in dir aufgewühlt hat, womit du nicht ganz einverstanden bist oder was auch immer. Auch das ist ja ein Erfolg des Ganzen, des Stücks, auch wenn es jetzt nicht positiv war. Also es ist ja auch immer schwer. Zum Beispiel, ich finde den Film Hör, ich denke da sehr oft drüber nach, weil ich einfach, ich finde toll von der Welt, die er aufmacht. Ich finde es aber jetzt kein Megafilm, den ich mega oft sehen will. Wenn mich aber jemand fragt, wie findest du den Film,
dann sage ich nicht, ja,
wie finde ich den Film, wie
kann man das jetzt sagen, gibt
es gut, gibt es schlecht, was finde ich daran
gut, was finde ich daran schlecht? Ich sage dir,
ja, ist ein guter Film.
Man macht dieses
Fass nicht auf, man will es auch irgendwie nicht.
Man will nicht sagen, was ist gut, was ist schlecht,
sage mir, und dann sage ich dir, mein Man will nicht sagen, was ist gut, was ist schlecht, sage mir und dann
dann sage ich dir, meinst du die Kamera,
wow, die Kamera,
dann kannst du ein Pamphlet halten darüber,
wie deine Kamera zu funktionieren hat.
Aber das ist nicht die Sinn der Sache.
Man kann da natürlich auf der anderen Seite
noch Filme als jetzt mehr als nur
Unterhaltung sehen und natürlich dann auch irgendwie
Ideologiekritik und Gesellschaftskritik
und so mit reinweben und sagen, das ist auch noch eine Aufgabe der Filme, das kann man natürlich auch noch bewerten und sagen, inwiefern hat das funktioniert. Ja, man kann vieles bewerten. Oder wie ist das Menschenbild in dem Film und so, aber wir Vollidioten können natürlich das primär nur auf der geschmacksoberflächlichen Sache bewerten und da ist natürlich dann die Frage, was man dann überhaupt aussagen will. Sind wir so, dass wenn wir ernst sprechen, dass wir bei Themen landen, dass wir bei grossen Zusammenhängen landen? Nee. Warum? Tun wir es trotzdem. Wir landen bei grossen Zusammenhängen gerade. Ich finde das sehr spannend, weil ich bin zum Beispiel, ich habe das Gefühl, ich werde krank. So, darüber könnte ich sprechen jetzt. Körperlich oder wie weißt du das? Ich meine, ich eine Erkältung bekomme. Ja. Ja, so war das gemeint. Und ich habe das Gefühl, da werde ich jetzt krank. Ich werde morgen vielleicht Halsschmerzen haben. Darüber sprechen wir nicht. Wir sprechen nicht über, ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Ding, Leute, die oft nachdenken, die verkopft sind, sprechen nicht gern über belanglose, in Anführungszeichen belanglose Dinge. Warum ist das so? Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Aber es fällt mir auch auf, so Smalltalk und so und irgendwie dann auch ... Man landet schnell bei einer großen Zusammenhänge, gefühlt.
Ja.
Also ich könnte auch, glaube ich, wenn ich einen Film machen wollte, könnte ich den nicht über die kleinen Dinge des Lebens machen, sondern es wäre direkt ein Film über wie, was ist der Sinn der Menschheit, was ist, warum leben wir. Vielleicht ist es auch, weil wir eher so eine bewertende Instanz noch mit drin haben irgendwie. Weil auch euch verbringen manchmal Zeit mit Leuten, wo ich mir denke so, ich würde jetzt eigentlich lieber einen Film anschauen oder einen WoW spielen oder sowas. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob die anderen das auch immer so bewerten oder ob die nicht einfach da gar nicht drüber nachdenken und eher sich gehen lassen, um es jetzt positiv auszudrücken, einfach sagen, ach, ich bin mit Leuten unterwegs und irgendwie cool, wir gehen feiern und was trinken und gar nicht drüber nachdenken, was man stattdessen alles noch machen könnte und einfach in dem Moment sehen oder sowas, wogegen ich immer wieder denke, so, eigentlich würde ich jetzt gerne den und den Film sehen und das und das machen und man immer drüber und sich nicht so ganz gehen lassen kann, nicht so ganz locker in dem Moment ist, wo man einfach sagt, so ist es jetzt scheißegal, ob das jetzt perfekt ist gerade oder ob das jetzt nur 70 Prozent ist und irgendwie zu Hause Netflix schauen wäre, 90 Prozent.
So geht mir das genauso. Ich frage mich auch immer, also ich habe immer Opportunitätskosten im Kopf und ich habe, wenn ich mich abends erwische, wie ich, wenn ich Netflix gucke und ich habe Spaß dabei, sogar im Idealfall, denke ich darüber nach, was ich stattdessen machen könnte. Ich pausiere dann manchmal die Serie, die mir Spaß macht, und sage, okay, du sollst es vielleicht lieber an deinem Skript weiterschreiben oder so einen Scheiss, oder du sollst es lieber mal aufräumen oder du sollst Dinge machen, die dir Spaß machen. Und dann fällt mir ein, okay, was du gerade machst, macht dir ja eigentlich Spaß. Ich bin oft in dem Moment, ich bin oft mit der Situation unzufrieden, ich wäre meistens lieber woanders. Ich könnte egal wo sein, ich wäre lieber woanders und ich denke mir, wenn ich im Freizeitpark bin, denke ich über den Heimweg nach, ich denke darüber nach, was ich stattdessen machen könnte. Und nicht mal, weil ich keinen Spaß habe, sondern einfach, weil ich mit dem Status quo per se unzufrieden bin. Wenn du zu Hause bist, denkst du an den Freizeitpark, wo du gerne hinbekommen bist, dass du es heute wieder nicht geschafft hast, da hinzugehen. Ja, aber wenn ich abends sage, nee, Leute, ich bleibe zu Hause, ich gucke einen Film, für mich, weil ich da mehr Bock drauf habe, als feiern zu gehen, dann denke ich mir, wenn ich zu Hause bin, ja, vielleicht hätte ich was anderes machen sollen. Ja. Und wenn ich weg bin, denke ich mir auf jeden Fall, ich bin lieber zu Hause. Ja, man fängt dann auch irgendwie diese Recherche, wonach bewertet man dann auch solche Aktivitäten, ne? Also das Perfide ist ja, dass wir auch in einer Arbeitswelt sind, wo es ja durchaus sinnvoll ist, sich einen Film anzuschauen oder eine Serie anzuschauen oder so oder Dinge zu kennen, moderne Sachen zu kennen und oft habe ich dann auch ein schlechtes Gewissen dafür, dass ich keine Serie geschaut habe an einem Abend, sondern nur irgendwie rumgelöbelt habe und einfach Sachen auf Reddit mich durchgeklickt habe und gar nichts gemacht habe. Ich hätte jetzt auch einen Film anschauen können und hätte wieder was gelernt oder hätte wieder irgendwie mehr meinen visuellen Erfahrungshorizont erweitert, den ich vielleicht hätte nutzen können bei dem nächsten Projekt oder was auch immer.
Also man fängt dann auch an, irgendwie alles zu relativieren, aber ja. Macht man, also ja, haben wir uns das ausgesucht, weil wir so sind oder sind wir so, weil wir uns das ausgesucht haben? Ich weiß es nicht, also da ich, da die Tatsache, dass ich hier bin, eine Eins-zu-eintausend-Chance war, glaube ich, hätte ich genauso gut auch was anderes machen können, weil es ist mehr oder weniger hauptsächlich Glück, dass ich hier bin und dass ich hier so reingekommen bin und mich dann in der Form entwickelt habe. Aber das glaubst du nicht wirklich. Doch, auf jeden Fall. Das glaube ich dir immer nicht, das hast du auch schon mal gesagt. Also ja, wie gesagt, das ist ja immer so ein Mischding, aber... Ja, aber ich glaubte, dass... ich glaub ich glaube, ich unterstelle dir, dass du wesentlich unbescheidener bist als das, was du gerade sagst. Man kann sich das ja auch so schlecht immer so vor Augen halten. Du kannst ja nicht durchs Leben gehen und denken, das ist reines Glück, dass ich hier bin. Dann funktionierst du ja auch nicht. Du brauchst ja auch ein gewisses Selbstbewusstsein. Und gerade wenn du vor der Kamera stehst und Unsicherheit herrscht und du den Kameramann anschaust und siehst, der findet den Sketch nicht lustig, dann musst du zu einem gewissen Grad schon sagen, nee, ich hab's schon drauf irgendwo. Ansonsten funktionierst du einfach nicht, sonst kommst du nicht weiter. Du musst schon wissen, auch wenn dir das alle hier im Raum nicht lustig findet und der Tonmann versteht den Sketch nicht und der Kameraassistent irgendwie schaut die ganze Zeit betrübt und schüttelt den Kopf und versteht nicht, was du meinst, du musst trotzdem der im Raum sein, der sagt, das ist kein Bullshit. Woher nimmst du dieses Selbstbewusstsein, wenn du wirklich glaubst, dass du nur durch Glück hier bist? Ja, das muss man sich einfach aufbauen. Also der erste Schritt war Glück, ab dann vielleicht nicht mehr. Und du musst es einfach auch einfach hervorbringen. Du musst jetzt einfach sagen, das ist genau wie, keine Ahnung, ein Familienvater, der wenn es brennt, einfach sagt, ja, nee, es ist einfach meine fucking Aufgabe, der Starke zu sein oder mich um irgendwas zu kümmern, musst du auch als Typ vor der Kamera sein, so, nee, ich muss da jetzt dran glauben, wenn ich dran glaube, bricht alles zusammen, ich muss jetzt von mir ausgehen, dass ich der Beste bin und man kann Selbstbewusstsein einfach erzeugen, du kannst fünf Minuten, bevor du auf die Bühne trittst, kannst du sagen, so, nee, ich bin der krasseste Typ der Welt, ich hab's mega drauf, irgendwie. Kann man das? Das kann man, das geht. Womit? Du musst dir das einfach einreden, du hast das unter Kontrolle. Du musst einfach Sachen entwickeln, wo du weißt, du musst zu gewissen Zeiten funktionieren können. Aber das ist wirklich interessant. Das darf nicht von der Tageszeit ablaufen. Du kannst nicht einfach sagen, oh, ich hab gerade erfahren, keine Ahnung, meine Oma liegt im Krankenhaus, jetzt kann ich nicht mehr auf die Bühne, es geht nicht, es geht einfach nicht. Du musst dich in einen Status bringen, wo du funktionieren kannst, egal was ist. Als ich das Auto angefangen habe, war ich dann noch mega jung und mega unsicher. Ich war nicht unsicher, ich war auf dem Gebiet unsicher, weil es neu für mich war. Und dann habe ich mir irgendwo gelesen, dass wenn man grinst, dass dann die Muskeln ans Gehirn übertragen, okay, du bist gerade fröhlich, weil das ist wirklich so, das ist eine ganz einfache Ursache-Wirkung-Zusammenhang. Es geht auch andersrum, du grinst nicht nur, wenn du fröhlich bist, du bist auch fröhlich, wenn du grinst. Du bist wirklich fröhlich, wenn du grinst. Also die Muskeln lösen gewisse Hormonanschüttungen im Gehirn aus. Das habe ich immer irgendwo gehört, dass man das mindestens 60 Sekunden machen muss. Und mein Weg von der U-Bahn bis zur Firma hat ungefähr so lange gedauert. Das ist kein Scheiß. Ich bin jeden Morgen grinsend, mich zwingend zu grinsen, in die Firma gelaufen, um da dann glücklich zu sein, weil ich dachte, du musst dich entertaining fühlen, wenn du Unterhaltung machen willst. Was es gebracht hat, weiss ich nicht, Aber auf der anderen Seite bin ich noch hier, von daher vielleicht ist es die Mega-Idee gewesen. Aber auch dieses You're here for a reason ist schon auch eine grosse Motivation. Ich war oft in Situationen, wo ich in Positionen war, wo ich mir dachte, eigentlich verdiene ich das noch nicht. Das ist schon die grösste Antrieb, es hat schon einen Grund, warum du hier bist. Und auch wenn du irgendwo weißt, dass der Grund vielleicht nicht existiert, musstest du einreden, dass es einfach so ist. Und Pete Davidson hat mal gesagt, er hat immer diesen Shower Talk. Immer wenn er duscht, versucht er sich wirklich ganz bewusst maximal sein Selbstbewusstsein aufzubauen. Er sagt, ich habe das und das schon erreicht, ich bin, keine Ahnung, erst 21, aber bin schon bei SNL, ich habe das und das schon geschafft, ich habe den Award gewonnen. Das ist der einfachste Show-Talk als Pete Davidson. Ja, klar, Pete Davidson hat es natürlich ein bisschen leicht, aber jeder hat irgendwelche Dinge, auf die er stolz sein kann und die er schon geschafft hat, oder wo er nicht irgendwie, oder die er zumindest probiert hat, wo er gesagt hat, ich bin zu dem Casting gegangen und das habe ich geschafft, auch wenn ich es nicht gewonnen habe oder so, jeder hat irgendwelche solche Sachen und der hat wirklich gesagt, also wirklich bewusst arrogant sein manchmal, bewusst sagen, ich bin der krasseste Typ, den es überhaupt gibt, um einfach so ein Selbstbewusstsein aufzubauen, weil irgendwann muss es abrufen und es bedingt sich ja auch. Gerade, also ich meine, das ist für 99 Prozent der Zuhörer wahrscheinlich irrelevant, weil die nicht in solchen Berufen arbeiten, aber das bedingt sich ja, du bist ja besser vor der Kamera, wenn du denkst, du bist der krasseste Typ der Welt.
Das glaube ich und ich glaube auch
an den festen Grundsatz, es gibt keine
verkannten Genies. Es gibt keine
Leute, die da draußen sitzen und die es
drauf haben, die nicht
die Chance bekommen
irgendwann. Ich glaube,
das Leben ist so eine
Welle aus
Höhen und Tiefen natürlich, aber auch aus Chancen. Die ganze Zeit kommen die Chancen entgegen. Die können so klein sein und so wie auch immer, scheißegal, aber du musst, wenn du gut bist, ist die erstbeste Chance, die dich dazu bringt, Erfolg zu haben. Ja, auf der anderen Seite, ich weiss es ja nicht, also ich meine, Erfolg ist ja auch einfach harte Arbeit und dranbleiben und einfach auch irgendwie 50 Neins zu überleben, um dann irgendwie zu einem Jahr zu kommen. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ich weiß nicht, wenn ich damals nicht von bei der Frank-Elsa Masterclass genommen worden wäre, kann es gut sein, dass ich einfach gar nichts gemacht hätte und irgendwie dann einfach irgendwo fünftes Semester weiter studiert hätte und nichts passiert wäre. Das kann man jetzt nicht sagen, aber ich kann mir gut vorstellen. Also es ist ja, harte Arbeit ist ja auch einfach wichtig und dann irgendwie dafür zu arbeiten, dass wenn dein glücklicher Moment kommt, du was vorweisen kannst. Vorzuzeigen hast, ja. Das ist komplett, sehe ich genauso. Es schreiben ja auch immer viele Leute so, wie kommst du in die Medien und so. Ich wurde noch interviewt, wie ich in meinem Alter hier Comedy-Autor sein kann. Und es ist schon interessant, was man da für Fragen gestellt bekommt, die einem dann zum ersten Mal auch zum Nachdenken anregen und so. Aber ich habe ja auch keinen Vergleich. Also ich habe kein Paralleluniversum, was ich genau bis jetzt erlebt habe, wo ich es nicht geworden bin. Von daher kann ich da gar nicht so viel zu sagen. Da ist man dann auch der falsche Ansprechpartner als jemand, der es schon mal geschafft hat, irgendwie, ohne zu wissen, warum. Ja, das hat mal irgendjemand gesagt, dass man eigentlich die Leute interviewen müsste, die es nicht geschafft haben. Hast du das nicht mal gesagt?
Ja, ich glaube, das fand man so in so Buch, gerade so bei Unternehmern oder Erfindern oder so, weil die Leute, die es geschafft haben, eigentlich die Ausnahme sind. Und man eigentlich eher mit den Leuten reden sollte, die es nicht geschafft haben und rausfinden sollte, warum die es nicht geschafft haben, anstatt die Leute rauszufinden, die es geschafft haben. Ich meine, da geht es glaube ich nur um die absoluten Genies der Zeit. falsifiziert, das sage ich jetzt richtig an euch, versucht nicht herauszufinden, warum Leute es geworden sind, sondern versucht auszuschließen, was Gründe dafür sein könnten, dass es nicht geklappt haben könnte. Da muss man versuchen, dann seinen Weg zu finden. Gott, ey. Die Linie ist sehr fein zwischen Kalenderspruch und tatsächlichen Erfahrungen, die man gemacht hat. Es ist schwierig. Es ist vor allem schwierig, also wir merken ja gerade, wir haben Leuten quasi nichts zu sagen, auch so pretentious Bullshit, wenn wir ernst sind. Ja, weil wir halt leider, das Problem ist, wir haben leider die falsche Position, weil wir haben es einfach, wir sind halt schon da, wo wir sein wollen. Nö, stimmt nicht. Also na gut, aber auf dem Weg zumindest. Also ich würde schon sagen, dass ich schon meinen Traumjob habe und momentan lebe. Und das ist halt die einfachste Position, weil du kannst entweder allen Leuten sagen, ja es ist ja nicht so schwer, weil für dich war es nicht schwer. Was die Leute aber natürlich zu Recht sagen, ja halt die Fresse, du hast gar keine Ahnung. Das ist genau wie wenn ein Lottogewinner sagen würde, ja es ist nicht so schwer, Geld zu verdienen. Und auf der anderen Seite können die natürlich nur ihre eigene sie leben in ihrer eigenen Welt, die nichts mit der Welt zu tun hat von den Leuten, die vielleicht auf der anderen Seite stehen. Manchmal glaubt man, man will Dinge erreichen, ich spreche auch da für mich, aber man will, ich glaube, wenn man es erreicht hätte, würde man merken, das will man gar nicht so unbedingt. Also der Weg dahin zeigt einem ja auch immer eher, was man, also je mehr man macht, desto mehr entdeckt man auch, was man machen will. Ja. Deswegen, ich habe zum Beispiel oft, als ich hier zum ersten Mal in der Redaktion stand und vom Begriff Autor gehört hatte, wusste ich, ich will Autor werden. Da forderte ich immer, ich will so Redaktionstyp sein, halt Redakteur. Aber ich dachte, Redakteur denken sich Dinge aus und so, aber das ist eigentlich nur ein falsches Wort dafür. Deswegen bin ich hingegangen und habe gedacht, was ich eigentlich sein will. Deswegen, glaube ich, ist es wichtig, einfach zu gehen, weil dann merkt man, ob man in die falsche Richtung geht oder nicht. Auf jeden Fall erfahrt er erst dann, was es überhaupt für Möglichkeiten gibt und was man überhaupt machen können sollte, weil es gibt ja auch gerade, glaube ich, in jeder Branche so unendlich viele Berufe und Sachen und Aufgaben, von denen man ja nichts weiss. So, du hast ja, wenn du einen Film siehst und den Abspann siehst, du hast ja keine Ahnung, was sie davon machen. Und erst wenn du an einem Filmset mal stehst, verstehst du überhaupt, was gibt es überhaupt für Jobs und was könnte ich da gut machen und was könnte mir gefallen? Ich glaube, bei so einem Abspann sind 90 Prozent der Leute unglücklich mit dem Job.
Meinst du? Nein.
Doch, ich glaube nämlich, 90 Prozent von denen wollen, sind da nur als Station.
Ich glaube, der Keygrip will lieber was anderes machen als Keygrip. Ja, das kriege ich da.
Der Fahrer will vielleicht ...
Aber zum Beispiel bei unseren Produktionen und unseren Drehs, die wir so haben,
habe ich schon das Gefühl, dass locker 90 Prozent der Leute schon richtig Bock drauf haben, was sie machen.
Ist es vielleicht auch ein Luxus, mit solchen Leuten zu arbeiten, aber auf der anderen Seite, also so viel Euphorie und Bock, wie die reinliegen, also auch der Beleuchter, der immer nochmal sagt, nee, komm, lass das nochmal ein bisschen anders machen, so sieht es nochmal geiler aus. Und du denkst, halt deine Fresse, ich will nach Hause. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es ja cool, dass er so drin ist und sich denkt, okay, das ist jetzt mein Kunstwerk, das ich hier gerade baue und jeder am Set gerade das Gefühl hat, er versucht, das Grösse rauszuholen. Da habe ich schon das Gefühl, dass die schon da sind, wo sie sein wollen.
Ja, ich denke jetzt auch eher bei Filmen, wo Leute auch manchmal dann als Wegstation da sind, als die Praktikanten, die später mal Regisseur werden wollen, die dann auf dem Weg dahin halt als Keygrip im Abspann auftauen.
Was auch immer das ist, keine Ahnung. Weisst du es? Niemand weiss es. Ha, ein Abspann. Ich würde auch mal gerne einen Abspann. Ein richtig schöner, langer Abspann. Weiß auf Schwarz. Hat er mal irgendwer mit gebrochen? Bestimmt, aber kenne ich vielleicht nicht. Ich glaube, sogar bei Seven läuft der Abspann falsch rum.
Ah.
Ich wusste auch, was da der ... Warum bei Seven?
Weil die wollten Kevin Spacey nicht am Anfang zeigen, weil sie sonst ...
Weil die suchen ja immer den Mörder, wir spoilern jetzt Seven, die suchen ja immer den Mörder und wenn du am Anfang schon siehst, Kevin Spacey spielt mit und der wird nicht in den ersten zehn Minuten gezeigt, weißt du, das ist der Täter, weil der erst am Ende gezeigt wird. Meinst du gerade Usual Suspects? Nee, Seven, auf jeden Fall, glaube ich, war das der Grund, warum sie ihn nicht am Anfang gezeigt haben, den Namen, weil die Leute schon gedacht hätten, ah, so ein großer Star spielt mit und ist in den ersten zehn Minuten nicht zu sehen, also spielt er nicht einen der Detektives, also muss er dann den Böse bespielen. Ja, klar, klar. Und dann wurde er am Ende als Erster gezeigt und dann ist der Abspann aus irgendeinem Grund andersrum gelaufen. Ich weiß auch nicht mehr genau, warum. Keine Ahnung. Weil der Abspann kommt ja normalerweise nach der Story, von daher könnten die dann dadurch sagen, dass Kevin Spacey aber gut ist. Ich weiß noch, als wir Shooters Money Tour angeschaut haben, sind wir alle während des Abspanns rausgegangen, ich habe das mit meiner Familie angeschaut, komischerweise, und mein Bruder ist noch sitzen geblieben, weil er dachte, da kommt noch eine Szene, und dann kam auch tatsächlich nach dem Abspann noch eine Szene, und dann kam er zum Autogrand und hat gesagt, ja, da kommt noch eine Szene, und er so, ja, was war die Szene, und dann hat er erklärt, was die Szene ist. Dann kann ich mich komischerweise, obwohl das jetzt irgendwie schon 15 Jahre her ist oder was auch immer, immer noch genau erinnern daran, dass er zurückkam, so alsatzsucher, der sich immer noch die Szenen irgendwie raussuchte.
Ja, aber er kam noch so Blupers da mit Sicherheit. Ja, aber ganz am Ende, nach dem Abspann, kam noch mal Winnie-Touch, der Pinke, noch mal aufs dem Pferd. Ein miserabler Klischee-Film, also furchtbar. Winnie-Touch! Würde der heute noch mal funktionieren, wenn er heute rauskommen würde? Ich würde Major Shitstorm auslösen. Ich glaube, wenige Künstler haben so perfekt ihre Zeit getroffen wie Michael Bulli-Herbig, der genau zur richtigen Zeit und Otto, der genau zur richtigen Zeit genau den richtigen Humor getroffen hat. Ich glaube, heute macht er einen schönen Cash-In für Haribo. Otto hat nächste Woche Dienstag spielt er irgendwo ein Konzert, wo ein Kommilitone ist.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Das ist so aus der Zeit gefallen.
Das ist so unzeiggemerkt. Das kann man sich ja nicht mehr angucken. Auch so Bulli-Show oder diese Bulli-Parade. Das finde ich auch so ganz außer Zeit gefallen. Ich war mal in Ostfriesland im Otto-Haus, da wo der, glaube ich, geboren wurde oder gestorben ist oder irgendwie eins von beiden oder irgendwie ein Museum gemacht hat. Das war ein Gag, das war der vierte Gag. Wow. Ja, auf jeden Fall war ich da und hab da die Ottifanten angeschaut. Das finde ich gut, dass du das gemacht hast. Nächstes Thema, Hegel. Hegel reimt sich auf Hebel. Du, du verleitest mich nicht zu einer Pointe, du, ich bin on edge. Ja, ich glaube, Philosophie ist dann auch irgendwann bei mir vorbei. Ich glaube, da kannst du mit mir nicht so gut drüber reden, weil ich glaube, du bist so wesentlich fairer mal drin. Nee, habe ich auch immer drin. Okay. Nee, also ich werde krank, glaube ich, was sehr selten der Fall ist, aber einmal im Jahr werde ich krank. Du wirst krank, ich werde fett, wir sind komplett im Untergang geweiht. Aber du kannst was dagegen tun, aktiv. Also das verstehe ich auch nicht. Ich finde, man merkt so schnell, dass man krank wird, dass man denkt, da muss es irgendwie ein Mittel geben, was man dann nehmen kann. Also vielleicht bin ich da auch ein bisschen abergläubisch, aber ich bin großer Verfechter des Placebo-Effekts. Ich wirklich versuche, alles mit Placebo-Effekten zu lösen. Und ich bin fest von der Überzeugung, dass wenn du merkst, du wirst krank und dann sagst, oh shit, jetzt bin ich krank, ich lege mich ins Bett und fieber, dann bist du down sofort. Du musst wirklich deinem Körper vormachen, jetzt ist fucking Stalingrad, wir stehen unter Beschuss von Artillerie, ich kann jetzt einfach nicht krank werden, forget it, no chance, du kannst nicht krank werden und dann sagt der Körper auch, gut, dann nächstes Jahr halt nochmal, schauen wir nochmal vorbei und dann wirst du auch nicht krank, glaube ich. Ja, aber aus so einer Abwehrhaltung raus, glaube ich, funktioniert das nicht, ich glaube eher aus so einer positiven, ach und wenn schon. Ja, das ist der Placebo-Effekt,-Effekt. Ja, aber Stalingrad ist, glaube ich, da wird man schon krank. Naja, aber du darfst es halt einfach nicht locker lassen und du musst es halt einfach weitermachen und weiter Stress machen und sagen, ich kann nicht krank werden, weil ich bin nicht krank. Ich glaube, sobald du anfängst, dich so zu verhalten, als wärst du krank, wirst du auch krank. Genau das ist ja der Nocebo-Effekt in dem Fall, der umgekehrt, dass es dir schlechter geht. Aber ansonsten ist echt, glaube ich, vor allem das Tolle ist ja, du kannst ja auch einen Placebo-Placebo-Effekt haben. Selbst wenn du weißt, es ist nur ein Placebo-Effekt, funktioniert es trotzdem. Das ist ja das Tolle. Du kannst dich ja bewusst verarschen und es funktioniert trotzdem. Das ist ja das Geniale. Du brauchst halt nur dieser positive Impuls, den du brauchst. Ja, genau. Dieser positive Impuls, das wird mir jetzt helfen. Auch wenn ich weiss, es wird mir nicht helfen, hast du trotzdem dein Gehirn, kriegst trotzdem das exakt gleiche Signal. Zum Beispiel, es gab immer eine Zeit, wo ich massiv zugenommen habe, das war kurz vor die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse, und da habe ich tatsächlich so stark zugenommen, dass ich so Stretchmarks am Bauch habe. Weil ich so stark zugenommen habe, dass mein Bauch so stark gewachsen, dass ich wie so eine schwangere Frau so Stretchmarks hatte. Und dann habe ich angefangen abzunehmen und dachte mir, fuck it, ich muss diese Stretchmarks irgendwie loswerden. Und da hieß dann, habe ich so gelesen, was man machen kann, irgendwie Feuchtigkeitskämme oder whatever. Und Vitamin C ist wichtig für die Regeneration der Haut, whatever. Und dann habe ich ja angefangen, so Vitaminsab-Tabletten zu nehmen, so Brausetabletten jeden Tag. Und die nehme ich immer noch, und seitdem bin ich nicht mehr krank geworden. Und ich glaube, das ist das ist auch einfach stark vom Placeboeffekt abhängig, dass ich mir einfach denke, ich bin ja gesund, wahrscheinlich sind diese Vitamintabletten kompletter Bullshit und die werden gar nicht aufgenommen durch den Magen und das ist alles Quatsch, aber als Placeboeffekt funktioniert das total gut und ich denke mir immer, hoffentlich lese ich nicht irgendwo eine Studie, die sind total nutzlos, weil dann funktioniert es nicht mehr, aber das stimmt nicht. Selbst wenn ich wissen würde, die sind komplett nutzlos oder selbst wenn ich da Salz oder Zucker reinstreuen würde und mir einrennen, würde es trotzdem noch funktionieren, auch wenn ich komplett weiß, es stimmt nicht, solange ich an den Placebo-Effekt glaube, nicht an den Effekt des Placebos, sondern an den Effekt selbst glaube, dann funktioniert es. Und das ist erstaunlich, aber es funktioniert wirklich so. Vielleicht bin ich auch einfach glücklich, dass ich einfach seit drei Jahren nicht mehr krank geworden bin, aber vielleicht hat es auch was damit zu tun. Vielleicht ist es auch, wenn du nicht rausgehst und die ganze Zeit in einem fucking destillierten PC sitzt. Destillierter PC. Ja, das ist das falsche Wort, verdammt. Klimatisiert, meinst du? Nein, desinfiziert. Ach so, desinfiziert. Aber macht auch nicht so viel Sinn.
Ja, ist auch ein bisschen ermüdend, so eine ernste Folge.
Ach hey, wir haben es fast geschafft, ey, passt schon.
Machen wir noch gute fünf Minuten.
Erzähl du noch was aus deinem Privatleben, was bedrückt dich?
Hättest du gerne mehr ... Ich lese gerade.
Also, ich glaube das Gefühl, du warst diese Woche teilweise ein bisschen angespannt, habe ich das Gefühl gehabt. Ich habe dir erzählt, dass ich angefangen habe, das neue Harry Potter Buch zu lesen. Ja. Und du hast mich angegangen wie so ein Schulbully. Also du hast gesagt, das ist gar kein Scherz, du hast wirklich gesagt, du bist da nicht etwas zu alt für. Das ist ganz ernst, hast du das gesagt. Das war ein Gag. Mhm. Ich hab ... also ...
Wir kennen uns mittlerweile schon ein bisschen lang,
manchmal hast du so Phasen, wo du so was raushaust.
Und das fand ich ... da hab ich drüber nachgedacht, auch lang.
Hat dann auch abends, bevor ich das Harry Potter-Buch angefasst hab,
hab ich drüber nachgedacht.
Hast du den Playboy rausgeholt stattdessen?
Oh Mann!
Oh, der fünfte Gag!
Sieg, sieg, sieg, sieg!
Aber bin ich jetzt der schlechtere Komiker, weil ich dieses Spiel keinelosebekommen habe? Nein, du könntest dich besser beherrschen. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ja, und da habe ich drüber nachgedacht. Und ich habe es für völlig einen Quatsch abgestempelt. Ja. Vielleicht war es auch einfach ein Scherz von dir, aber das glaube ich nicht so richtig. Doch, war es auch. Ich glaube, in jedem Scherz schwingt auch so ein bisschen ... Ich habe gegenüber meinem Professor heute Scherze gemacht. Uuuuh. ja, so meine ich jetzt gar nicht, aber ich meine, ich habe so ein bisschen, ich glaube, es kommt auch so eine Haltung heraus, so, ja, du willst den auch gerade so ein bisschen, du nimmst den nicht so richtig ernst, du willst den auch gerade so ein bisschen austeilen. Ich glaube, bei jedem Gag schwingt auch ein gewisses Quäntchen Wahrheit mit. Ja, ich weiss nur, dass ich diese Harry Potter Bücher überall sehe, irgendwie, dass die jetzt irgendwie verkauft wurden und ich denke, mich interessiert es halt gar nicht. Erstens, weil ich mir denke,
das ist nicht mehr die originale Harry Potter
drücke, wenn jetzt wirklich der nächste Teil rauskommt und die Geschichte
noch zu Ende ist, würde ich das vielleicht machen.
Du willst sofort, du hast den ersten Plan.
Irgendwie noch oben drauf, nochmal irgendwie
vier, hundert Jahre später und so.
Und dann kommst halt du mit deinem
Hartledereinband, mit dem Harry Potter-Lesezeichen,
wo man sieht, okay, das hat schon ein paar
Bücher durch, alles drin und dann halt mit den grossen Augen, oh, weißt du, was mit Ginny passiert ist und ich denke mir halt so, ja, weißt du, der andere Autor, mit dem unterhalte ich mich über Kafka und du kommst mit Ginny rein, aber es ist ja alles in Ordnung, Nerdkultur ist ja auch angesehen, das ist ja alles in Ordnung. Aber er ist auch so pretentious, ey. Die Hörer werden mich wahrscheinlich hassen, dafür, dass ich jetzt Anti-Harry, ich Ich bin nicht Anti-Harry Potter. Weißt du, warum die sich hassen, werden zu Recht, weil du sagst, wenn du einen Autor überhattest, habe ich über Kafka... Nein, das ist kein Gag. Nein, sie jetzt sagen, dass alles ein Gag ist. Mein Gott, das ist ein Podcast-Ufo. Ich kann nicht hier runterdrehen, das mache ich jetzt auch mal, weil ich habe mich gefreut über diese Folge, fand ich ganz toll, was wir heute gemacht haben, war mal ein Experiment, eigentlich fand ich nicht so toll, ich fand es ziemlich, Ich glaube, es war ziemlich pretentious, ein bisschen boring teilweise auch. Ich glaube, die ganzen Sympathiepunkte, die wir jetzt 77 Folgen lang gesammelt haben, haben wir uns in einer Folge verspielt. Was momentan auch gerade ist, wieder versucht, die Sympathie zurückzubekommen. Dieses selbstironische Understatement und so. Ja, fuck it. Haltet von uns, was ihr wollt, schreibt uns mehr oder weniger Mails oder einfach versucht uns mal genau gleich viele Mails zu schreiben, wie bislang, nicht mehr und auch nicht weniger. Genau, das wollen wir, wenn wir uns aus dieser Folge mitnehmen können, dann, es gibt nicht nur Ja oder Nein, es gibt auch ein ... Ist mir völlig egal.
Ist mir egal oder ist nicht so einfach, es liegt nicht so auf der Hand. Schaut doch jetzt am besten mal auf Patreon vorbei und lasst ein paar Kronen für das Podcast-Ufo da. Oder schaut doch mal bei Spreadshirt vorbei und holt euch ein lustiges T-Shirt, um allen Menschen da draußen zu zeigen. Wir müssen nämlich weg, weil es kommt ein neues, von Florentin gezeichnet. Ja, das stimmt. Wenn wir ab jetzt noch hundert T-Shirts verkaufen, kommt ein neues T-Shirt-Design auf den Markt. Ihr könnt euren Beitrag leisten. Jeder einzelne Einkauf ist ein Prozent weiter zum Ziel, dass wir ein neues T-Shirt-Design kreieren mit eurem Namen vorne drauf. Alle Hörernamen alle h hundert Hörernamen, die sich, nein, alle Hörernamen, die ab jetzt das T-Shirt kaufen, werden abgedruckt auf einem grossen T-Shirt, das wie so ein Abi-Shirt aussieht, wo ein ganz kleiner Druck, wo auch der Druck zu schlecht ist, als dass man die Namen lesen kann. Einfach zu schlecht. Aber kann das auch die lustige Form haben, die ganzen Namen?
Auch irgendwie kann das einfach das ganze Tische einnehmen.
Wir sind eine grosse L-Form.
Und das untere L ist das Podcast-UFO.
Das wir sozusagen der Quanten haben.
Wir sind die Punchline eurer Feedline.
Ist das schön? Wir sind die Punchline eures Lebens.
Das ist mega, das ist mega arrogant.
Wir sind die Punchline, wenn ihr die Feedline,
ihr seid unsere Feedline, ohne euch werden wir gar nichts.
Das ist schön zu sagen. Vielen, vielen Dank. Dankeschaui Leute! Wie immer, bis zum nächsten Mal!